sie war der stolz des baldeneysees im
ruhrgebiet das ausflugsschiff war nix im
sommer ist sie dann in der
jahrhundertflut die moore nixe in der
ruhe untergegangen wir zeigen ihnen das
einmal wo sich das abgespielt haben hat
in den tagen der jahrhundertflut die
wassermassen haben das historische
schiff durch eine schleuse wehranlage
dort in die ruhe gedrückt und dann ist
das boot die monika auf den grund
gesunken die spektakulären bilder des
dramas um die monex die vergessen wir
nicht jetzt soll die historische das
historische schiff endlich geborgen
werden rausgeholt werden aus der tiefe
aus der ruhe aber die bergung des 18
meter langen schiffs verzögert sich bis
heute
diese bilder während der jahrhundertflut
gehen um die welt ein schiff wirbelt
hilflos in den tosenden wassermassen der
ruhe bei mühlheim in nordrhein westfalen
es wird von den fluten mitgerissen von
einem wehr gestoppt und schließlich in
die tiefe gezogen
was hier mitte juli während der
verheerenden flutkatastrophe versinkt
ist ein stück geschichte es ist die
morning
kulturgut von nur 2 33 erst die erste
fähre an beiden wir haben wir ja vor der
verwahrlosung gerettet aus dem
moor sage ich mal wiesmoor die schon
gefahren mit mehreren gruppen
interessierten bürgern das war eine
tolle sache nach ende der flut wird die
moore nixe schließlich bei
aufklärungsflügen mit einer drohne knapp
unter der wasseroberfläche gesichtet
doch es vergehen monate bis endlich mit
der bergung begonnen werden kann
zahlreiche helfer koordinieren tage lang
den technisch komplizierten
einsatztaucher teams kräne und
mitarbeiter der feuerwehr sind am
aufwendigen projekt beteiligt doch
gerade die schlechteste stelle sich nur
die man sich hier aus lenken kann alles
andere wäre gar nicht so schlimm gewesen
ist am fluss bereich an der seite
abgesunken wurde das relativ schnell
geborgen worden aber hier hinterher kein
zugang von der anderen seite
naturschutzgebieten und musste durch
bäume und büsche das ist ein riesen
kraftakt aber die mixa hat sich noch nie
unterkriegen lassen sogar ein
bombentreffer im zweiten weltkrieg
stoppt sie nicht und so hoffen alle dass
das ausflugsschiff auch nach diesem
vorfall bald wieder auf dem baldeney see
schippern
die bergung der alten mauern nixe die
verfolgt unser reporter sebastian bringe
er ist für uns dort vor ort guten morgen
sebastian hat man die alte dame denn
schon wieder irgendwie an die
wasseroberfläche holen können
ja also die bergung ist in vollem gange
und der kollege hinter der kamera der
sucht jetzt einmal ganz dicht heran da
sehen wir da hinten diese gelben
luftballons das sind sogenannte hebel 6
die sind mit pressluft gefüllt und mit
denen wird das fragt ganz langsam
angehoben und wenn wir jetzt mal da
zwischendurch gucken dann sehen wir die
monik sie ist wieder oberhalb der
wasseroberfläche
sie ist wieder aufgetaucht und wird
wahrscheinlich in den nächsten zwei
stunden schon mit einem kran aus dem
wasser die junge gehievt werden
weiß man schon wie es ihr geht es der
more nixe wie sie das ganze dort unter
wasser überstanden hat
ja die moniques hat zwei monate mehr als
zwei monate sogar auf dem grund der hohe
gelegen und man kann es sich kaum
vorstellen aber das schiff soll
tatsächlich immer noch schwimmfähig sein
es gibt wohl einen riss auf der
backbordseite es ungefähr einen halben
meter lang der wird gepflegt und man
hofft sogar dass das boot in ungefähr
einem vielleicht anderthalb jahren
wieder auf der rur schippern wird
dann glaubst du wird die bergung der
heute abgeschlossen sein das wird ja
toll sein hier mal wieder in die augen
zu schauen heute herford nächste wann
können wir damit rechnen auch hier
während unser live senden und sebastian
möglicherweise könnte das sein dass es
während der live-sendung passieren wird
dass das schiff mit einem kran aus dem
wasser gehievt wird aber man kann das
natürlich immer nur sehr schwer
vorhersehen man muss natürlich jetzt
auch noch gucken ob es noch weitere
schäden gibt und aber möglicherweise
könnte es klappen und dann werden wir
auf jeden fall live dabei sein
[Musik]